I'm being honest right I don't want to
be one of these [__] on television
hey hey hey hey hey oh I mean jackasses
sorry I'm sorry I apologize
I apologize
these guys should act like they know
everything Ernie I got the first check
uh that's the first time I've ever
cursed yeah because but some societies
like Koreans they might have a God
complex but they don't have a history of
Oppression oppressing another group of
people
each other right are you [__] out of
your mind what the [__] you don't think
Asians had they didn't Korean Koreans
didn't have slaves we didn't fly did
Koreans have slaves yeah Google that
yeah because I think that's wrong
somebody built them pyramids it wasn't
just somebody like you know Korea
obtain of slavery of any society in
history spanning 1500 years [__] off
that's not what it says stupid head my
eyes are blurry
I want to read it read it out loud piece
of [__] get close all right Korea
had the longest unbroken chain of
slavery of any society in history
holy [__] you guys are [__] scumbags
every industry has its own stereotype
every country has its own stereotype so
you work with obviously the Indian film
industry so much what is The Stereotype
they have about American films well I
think like aliens only land in America
yeah it's true
[Applause]
you know
this guy in the world in the world in
the whole world outside of your fiance
who's the hottest guy like the number
one dude
my used to be my type was Kim Jong-un
[Laughter]
personality not body time you know
because in North Korea that's a sign of
power
yeah because if you don't everybody's
starving like me so small so if you're
fat that means you got money because
nobody lived long enough to get bored
so if you're old and fat more than fat
so you are very very sexy Harvey
Wednesday
okay Harry Styles you like Harry Styles
I agree my wife love you very much does
she yeah her name is Sarah Sarah yeah
can you look into the camera
Sarah
you have the best husband
okay can you do me a favor
can you keep my wife's name out of you
I would do that before I start my
hilarious stories
I was wondering if you could just turn
the teleprompter off for a second I just
want to speak from the heart
I just quickly I wanted to say that uh
um
now turn it back on I I I I I
can't think of anything but um
anyway Adam's always been a [__] can
you make it bigger
um
you know it's amazing the career Adam
has had if you don't know this four
billion dollars in movies with this much
talent it's unbelievable
how did Kevin Hart and Dwayne The Rock
Johnson's Bromance begin
well his career was it was over he
needed help so naturally what do they do
call the okay heart
I came on board changed that man's life
by the way you're welcome
you're welcome because we know the truth
before me he had that stupid movie Tooth
Fairy we all knew what was happening
after that
then boom Central Intelligence
choose to the Moon Chris Rock oh come on
man okay okay I got smacked by the
softest person in the world
hey
hey Richard Pryor man that's insane that
you asked me to do Pride cause I'm on
national television and I can't say a
damn thing so acting is an art uh it's
not a science
um go on go on
wait is something wrong did you no man
did you put a filter on me
no what is going on are you doing this
you know I think you must have
accidentally turned on a filter with
one of your big fat fingers or something
like that yeah I knew you were gonna
pull something dumb like you were such a
child I'm so sick and tired of dealing
with your
[Applause]
you know what why don't you take your
little question in your little show and
shove it up your big hairy ass you know
I'm working on our president as we speak
Joe
so it says very sincere come on
I'm not kidding around serious
I love when he whispers I love when he's
like my dad used to do that Adam Sandler
Mark Twain Prize
because he did a lot of great movies
foreign
who if you got into a bar fight yeah and
you had to have Dwayne The Rock Johnson
or ice cube with you who would you
choose to help you in a bar fight in a
bar fight yes I'm going Cube you're
gonna be cute why not that big monster
that we call Dwayne we gonna win the
moment we may win the moment uh but you
know we don't know who we dealing with
and you know the threat of after that
moment people coming back
when I was young we used to play this
game called Gay Chicken they called it
uh I didn't name the game but I was you
know I was it your uncle was it neighbor
well the game was you you and a buddy
you'd grab each other's wiener right
penis they call it in those days some of
you guys call it penis yeah you grab it
and the first person to get an erection
lost the game right
so it's like arm wrestling first it's
the stupidest [__] game no it's not
no symbol I mean it is did you win did
you ever win or did you lose did you
lose a lot or did you win a lot oh I did
real well one season uh what is the gay
chicken season what does that go from
it's more of a win I would say it's an
Autumn game
we're co-workers get you Chris I mean
birthday presents for your 60th like
well Ernie and Ernie and Kenny will
probably do something nice and
thoughtful okay and Shaq is probably
gonna do what he do every Christmas give
us stuff that he's endorsing
because he is a guy who will like hand a
waitress a car he's like he does that
kind of a thing he does yeah he's a
really thoughtful guy
he loves making people happy yeah I love
working with him but that being said you
got to put some thought into people's
gifts
Alec Baldwin yeah he asked you how to
say how do you stay in shape so he does
100 push-ups and 100 sit-ups a day yeah
so he came up to me and he was like what
do you do and I and I didn't want to be
rude and say like I just still have
metabolism
[Laughter]
so to make him feel better I was like oh
man I do 100 push-ups and 100 sit-ups
every day and he was like got it
and then and then he got uh the the
Trump gig and so I would see him every
week and every time he would run into
law he'd be like 100 a day
and he started to do it and he lost like
100 pounds yeah he looks fantastic yeah
he's and it says it's all good to me
needs me to believe one or two things
about my brother Chris Rock
either he is the strongest black man
that God ever created
[Music]
he didn't act like he's gonna hit him
back he didn't do nothing
he didn't put his hands up I didn't see
his little claws curl up that [__] just
took it and then compliment it will on
The Slap
I can't believe it Will Smith just slap
me
it's the best moment in Oscar history
I'm never gonna wash my cheek again
the real Punk [__] was Will's cream from
his chair
keep my wife's name out your
[__] mouth
but this [__] Chris said that's a good
idea
[Applause]